I like you look at this rope moment yeah
yeah sexy yeah you know always got out a
little sexy to it nominated tonight
right new music what can you tease for
us about the new music um well I have a
some music coming out very soon I've
just been working just been in the
studio writing very present kind of
sonically with everything that I've been
creating so it's been cool to just kind
of delve into my own self explorative
worlds we saw an Armani and Camilla
reunite a little bit how are things
there you talk to her at all or how you
guys doing I think it's kind of yeah we
haven't really spoken or anything yeah
but it's like children
what are you moving forward with your
solo crews working on your stuff what do
you want for yourself like what do you
see is the vibe of what you want to put
out I think honestly I've just been
focusing on songwriting a lot like just
putting out my vision and putting out my
words and whatever it is that I wanted
to just say and what I've been wanting
to say for a while I like what you've
been wanting to say for a while like
what does that mean what inspires you or
what is what you don't want to just
different things about my life things
that I've gone through you know edit any
songwriter Krugers
[Music]
[Applause]